- Hello, this is Sal
Khan of the Khan Academy.
I'm here with David
Coleman who's president
of the College Board and
we're excited to together
announce the first launch
of our collaboration
between the College Board
and the Khan Academy
to create the first ever
official SAT preparation
for the new SAT.
And what I'm personally
really excited about
is that this is a very different SAT.
It's much simpler, it's much more focused
on the things that students
actually learn in school.
The vocabulary is vocabulary
that you would actually
use in life as opposed
to these kind of crazy,
classic SAT words.
- When we redesigned the SAT,
starting three years ago,
our whole aim actually was
to put students more at ease.
We eliminated the penalty for
wrong answers, as you know.
We want students to be able
to do their personal best
on the exam to show what they know
and it's also why we partnered
with you with Khan Academy,
to provide the best, world
class, free test preparation
in the world, right here, working together
close with you to make sure it focuses
on what the exam measures
and helps kids advance.
So I think what's so
exciting about Khan has done
is whatever level of
performance students are at,
whether they're behind in math,
even far behind in math, they can start
with where they're confident and strong
and build on those strengths
to get more and more ready
for PSAT, for SAT, and
really ready for college
and career readiness
'cause that's the core now
of what those exams measure.
- Yeah, and what I wanna
stress for everyone is
a lot of what we've been focused on
with our team here at Khan Academy,
as software engineers,
the designers, scientists,
have been working on a
personalization platform
where students go, they can
take some practice tests,
some practice questions,
and then based on that,
the software is trying to say,
well what's the next best
thing they should work on
to get more practice so that they can
advance in the best possible way.
So there's really no reason why someone
should feel intimidated.
It's all stuff that they've seen in school
and they're gonna be able to get
as much practice as they need.
- So go for it and do your best.
- All right.